[Musique]
deux fautes i know the lady est ce que
vous savez pourquoi on me surnomme ainsi
5 x 8 40 5 x 8 mille quarante mille
quand on parle de millions il dans le
jargon de la haute montagne ont fait
allusion aux 14 sommets qui culminent à
plus de 8000 mètres en himalaya et bien
moi j'en ai gravi cinq dont l'everest le
toit du monde
le point culminant de la planète
l'endroit au monde où on ne peut pas
aller plus haut le top
donc ce soir ce que j'ai envie de vous
raconter c'est comment on va au sommet
parce que je suis pas sûr qu'on vous ai
raconté ça souvent parce que pour moi il
faut être un suiveur pour arriver au
sommet donc je vais vous poser une
question et si pour arriver au top il
fallait être un follower mon expérience
avec la très haute altitude a démarré il
ya une quinzaine d'années avec une étape
importante en 2004 où j'ai gravi le mont
blanc sur un pari avec un ami qui était
malade et qui avaient leur rêve de
gravir le mont blanc et moi je les fais
le pari qu'on arriverait au sommet dans
l'année lui a réalisé son rêve
et moi j'ai démarré le mien georges est
né ensuite cap il m 5000 m 6000 m
7000 m et là on arrive à la barre
fatidique des 8000 est ce que je suis
capable
est-ce que je vais y arriver est ce que
je vais oser essayer en printemps 2012
que j'ai l'opportunité de rejoindre une
expédition suisse en himalaya au tibet
où nous avons gravi deux sommets de plus
de 8000 mètres en une saison le shisha
pangma et le chu-yo
et quand je suis rentré à genève j'ai
demandé des statistiques et il s'avère
qu'on ait qu'une dizaine de femmes dans
le monde à avoir gravi deux sommets de
plus de 8000 mètres en une saison
donc je peux vous dire que j'étais quand
même assez fier et pour venir aux socios
le sommet de cette montagne c'est un
immense plateau sommital comme ça qui
culmine à 8200 m et quand on arrive au
bout et qu'on bascule on se retrouve
face à l'everest
si vous connaissez quelqu'un qu'aggraver
le soleil ou d'ailleurs demandez lui ce
qu'il a vu et si vous dis pas qu'il a vu
l'everest c'est qu'il ait pas été en
haut il est resté à l'épaule et là il
s'est produit un truc incroyable c'est
que les sherpas de notre expédition sont
rentrés en contact radio avec les
sherpas qui se trouvait exactement même
moment au sommet de l'everest
donc c'est à une émotion absolument
intense un plan psychologique
certainement car deux ans après jour
pour jour le 25 mai 2014
j'étais au sommet de l'everest alors là
les gens ils ont commencé à me demander
de parler de mon histoire puisque un
everest avec tous les superlatifs que ça
comporte
ça se raconte mais plus pragmatiquement
tout d'abord un everest
c'est quand même cinquante cinq mille
francs suisses c'est cinquante cinq
nuits sous la tente au dessus de 5000 m
c'est trois douches en deux mois
medhat ces trois champs points ça vous
tente
c'est moins 15 sous l'un d'eux sous la
en moyenne la nuit donc imaginer sur les
camps d'altitude
c'est 200 yak pour transporter toute la
logistique du camp de base au camp de
base avancé mais un everest
c'est aussi dans la zone de morts
au-dessus des 8000 m six cadavres que
l'on croise jusqu'au sommet et comme je
suis rentré à genève j'ai mon copain
canadien jean philippe qui avec qui j'ai
beaucoup grimpé qui m'appellent et qui
dit alors raconte moi ton everest
comment c'était toi je racontais tout
puis tout d'un coup il dit et dix mois
après le 3e reçoit rochus il y avait
toujours le cadavre
alors j'ai dit ouais en effet oui oui
juste avant le sommet y avait un cadavre
il dit tu sais que c'est franck et
franck c'était son compagnon de cordée
en 2010 quand ils ont tenté l'everest
aussi sur la face nord comme nous et
jean-philippe lui a renoncé et franck
lui est parti seul sans oxygène et il
est mort d'épuisement
juste avant le sommet heureusement je
savais pas que c'était franck
franchement parce que je pense que ça
aurait été vraiment un facteur qui
m'aurait fait faire demi tour
un everest
c'est ça aussi avec quelques images
[Musique]
là je vais vous dire là c'est l'enfer
celles offertes et on est hyper motivé
fraîchement mieux ailleurs
si c'est ça
ce écologiquement autant de bruit tout
comme ça c'est affreux
regard des caméras
oh
c'est pas facile à battre c'est pas
facile du tout
mais on avait un ca à l'épaule est
possible
21h45 22 heures passées dehors car avec
les lunettes de soleil aussi j'ai pour
le bon là c'est un moment quand même
assez exceptionnel parce qu'on se sent
très haut physiquement esthétiquement le
paysage
on domine le paysage et puis un moment
donné je me retourne parce que je sens
le soleil émerger et la bonne heure je
vois sophie arriver son pantalon jaune
est vraiment lé voilà dans laxe de la
caméra dans l'acte de la grande arène
est le lever de soleil derrière voilà
moi je garde cette image super forte à
ce moment là
c'est fort
vas-y
[Musique]
oh
alors je préfère je préfère vous montrer
ces images parce que franchement c'est
une telle émotion quand on est sur le
toit du monde comme ça que j'ai encore
pas trouvé vraiment les mots pour
exprimer ce que j'ai ressenti là haut
mais vous devez vous demander
je suis certainement guide de haute
montagne professionnels de la montagne
une performeuse oui mais non non non non
non moi je suis rien de tout ça moi j'ai
plutôt l'impression enfin j'ai envie de
me qualifier d'une dune madame tout le
monde qui grimpe par par passion et
détermination
ça vient de là on a cette envie d'aller
en haut là et puis ça marche s'ils
arrivent modestement mais efficacement
j'arrive en eau comme les grands
himalayiste donc il ya quand même
quelque chose est un secret dans ma
carrière professionnelle
j'ai plus souvent été qualifié ce qu'on
appelle communément d'un leader j'ai
travaillé dans le lot tellerie de luxe à
genève
j'ai travaillé aussi pour des grands
groupes cosmétiques comme un bon
français comme clarins
j'ai dirigé une société événementielle
financier est là badaboum 2008 la crise
un tout qui s'écroule
le business model on a survécu jusqu'en
et là on est obligé de fermer
l'entreprise et là j'ai envie de dire
merci la crise merci pourquoi pas parce
que j'avais un agenda vide
c'est une page blanche et j'avais du
temps parce qu'un 8000 ces deux mois
donc il faut du temps et c'est là donc
je pars pour mon aventure du
shishapangma et du true you et
j'enchaîne avec l'everest en 2014 et
ensuite en 2015
je suis au sommet du gasherbrum ii au
pakistan et cette année j'étais au
sommet du makalu qui culmine à 8400 80 m
au népal
donc ça marche
et j'y vais et j'enchaîne donc
maintenant vous savez qui je suis ce que
je fais douche bien je vais vous
expliquer comment comment ça marche
parce que de nouveaux je reviens à mon
introduction
c'est en suivant qu'on arrive au sommet
donc je vais vous expliquer ce que c'est
que pour moi le follower chip un leader
seul il va nulle part d'un leader et son
tour de followers et bon montagne c'est
la même chose
un guide de haute montagne s'il est seul
c'est un performeur ok donc un guide si
son tour et va prendre des alpinistes
avec lui donc pour moi le meilleur
exemple celles accordées
vous pouvez avoir le meilleur guide de
haute montagne de la planète
si les alpinistes qui sont accrochés à
s'accordent ils sont pas compétents ils
n'iront jamais au sommet donc je vais
même aller plus loin pour moi si les
compétences des followers qui donne la
sécurité au leader le guide idées devant
il a la vision de la montagne
l'expérience icaunais son itinéraire et
tout mais il est pas infaillible
il peut tomber dans une crevasse et si
les gars qui sont accrochés à sa corne
savent pas faire un moulage pour le
sortir du trou ils vont tous si tôt mais
est bon en entreprise c'est la même
chose
le follow chip
c'est ce que j'appelle le leadership du
follower mont everest
je peux vous le résumer en trois bons un
rêve un projet un sommet j'ai été leader
de mon projet j'ai cherché les fonds
j'ai trouvé la logistique j'ai aménagé
mon temps j'ai trouvé les personnes pour
m'accompagner
j'étais totalement leader de mon projet
et quand je suis arrivé sur la montagne
il y avait un guide de haute montagne
qui était leader mais le leader c'est
aussi le couple sur le camp de base qui
nous fait à manger tous les jours
le leader c'est le cervar le chef des
sherpas qui va coordonner la fixation
des cordes sur la montagne
le portage de l'oxygène le leader c'est
aussi le prévisionniste météo qui nous
envoie les bulletins tous les jours je
peux vous dire que celui-là il important
parce que si la météo elle est fausse et
ben on est en zone de mort de nouveau
donc le rôle il est interchangeable
on est leader et on est aux followers en
fonction du contexte dans lequel on se
trouve
est ce qu'il faudrait pas qu'en
entreprise sur la même chose le fola hot
chip
c'est l'esprit d'équipé si on m'assure
gasherbrum ii au pakistan dernier camp
d'altitude 7000 mètres sommet 8035 m
donc 1000 mètres de dénivelé n'a
peut-être qu'il faut un peu de montagne
1000 mètres de dénivelé s est elle si tu
delà ces extrêmes c'est énorme on a de
l'année jusque là on est la première
expédition donc il faut tracer on part à
dix on a mis 16 heures pour atteindre le
sommet qu'elle est à cette altitude
on peut rarement allé plus vite que
entre 3 et 5 secondes par pas c'est à
dire que vous prenez autre pied comptez
1 2 3 4 5 2 3 on peut pas progresser
plus vite avec l'hypoxie et la
complexité la raideur de la pente c'est
pas possible donc on se relaie à peu
près toutes les dix minutes
donc on est parti à dix on est arrivé à
troyes au sommet pour moi c'est une
vraie réussite des équipes seul j'y
serais jamais arrivé en entreprise c'est
la même chose
le follow chips et savoir gérer le doute
un follower
c'est pas un mouton un follower par
exemple sur l'everest
nous on est arrivé au camp 3 donc à 8300
m avec un temps épouvantable neigeait il
y avait du vent on était dans un
brouillard et là on reçoit un bulletin
météo qui nous dit fait beau je peux
vous dire que là vous avez le droit de
douter
non seulement vous avez le droit mais il
faut douter il faut le doute la peur
c'est des facteurs extrêmement bloquant
la et sortir de votre temps de laver
faire 3 4 pins et puis faire demi tour
ça y est jamais arrivée au sommet donc
là il faut prendre les radios font
rappeler le camp de base il faut
demander aux leaders il faut demander il
faut s'interroger vont reprendre un
bulletin météo
il faut être sûr que la météo va
s'améliorer dans le courant de la nuit
quand on va arriver au sommet donc en
entreprise c'est la même chose
donc en fait il faut avoir confiance en
soi il faut avoir envie de se dépasser
et surtout il faut être fier de ses
succès de followers parce que le
leadership n'est rien sans le follower j
-p
c'est comme une reine médailles à deux
faces l'une ne va pas sans l'autre
donc je vous repose la question et si
pour aller au top pour aller à votre top
faudrait pas être follower donc je vous
remercie de m'avoir écouté et surtout je
vous remercie de m'avoir suivi
[Applaudissements]